[Música]
[Aplausos]
ele é igual a uma solução viável nem
tomadas como encontrado fingia ué chave
cinco médicos descobriram que o cantor
durante a gravidez tinha dominado por
uma linha arrotar meu nosso marco sousa
després assassinado há uma parte do
chamado sua província do bié cotações e
as histórias são tão forte que acaba com
os acompanharam antes
sabe se que os filhos dessa criança
a doença também a sua
eu gosto é uma história real e bragança
enfim acho que o são paulo estava atrás
da outra o transtorno é exatamente
hospital vá muitos portugueses online ea
doutora é fato cardoso é tolerado na
show atrasada a criança enquanto e
desceu traz à tona fátima surgiu gostar
do fato com estatizado tudo que estava
para casa e se ela tem obrigado o
paciente estava grávida
nós pensamos assim mas cobravam tantas
você então lógico
esta imagem filho cansar a mulher que
está grávida
ao mesmo tempo em que oferece minc a
pressão surgiu e surge agora talvez um
pouco da história
[Música]
acordei de manhã em sua fala e
diminuição de 11 irmãos que era um dia
também fui fazer falta a sanção não
falar nada pensado em um sinal do
governo chávez ae
o foco é na mão esquerda e quando dizem
que temos que fazer é uma coisa que tem
que aprender a lidar com ela é a única
que se defina que há uma crise na área
ninguém merece
diziam que não repetirá pois desejo
viver a ofício datado não andré de vir e
depois muito apetite é a mãe consiga
descobrir que sim e ele vinha pensando
só em gratuito e 507 previdência sempre
que a terapia com um trator cinéma cima
depois é a ideologia é ilegal na
televisão mas em 2001 formal gente fiel
ao contrário ainda mais e não tinha
segurança não tenho que estar na linha
de frente ao brasil derrota
[Música]
e é uma criança normal eu falo cantor
que é alguém que conhece limites na vida
de paulo e do investimento em fita e eu
não conseguisse a justiça impossível eu
também nunca foi uma razoável fazer não
queria falar não quisesse
fui muito disse
o álbum frase que é cruel de roupa texto
já que sua presença como faz-tudo do
palmar e na balança cunhou umas horas
mais difíceis mas assim no passado com o
flash tem que ser fã é únicas por idade
é uma frança e também seria de inscrição
não vier ali tá chama bela
os outros quatro nestas histórias
enquanto este estava grávida só
descobriram que estava a pensar vai à
montanha russa de emoções no bié estão o
momento mais feliz da novela não sabia
sempre me liga do xix muitas mãos
foi essa inquietação com deu vontade de
observar o que é que ia na cabeça destas
coisas que eu ia no verão de 2007 em
barcelona
o fato teria muitas informações passadas
ao teresa
é o caso de provas entre capotado em uma
fria que queria ter vida real e via da
criança e céu as crianças e criatura se
era compatível
toda vez que eu vim a descobrir que as
instruções o tempo de intervenção
regimento household afeta cerca de uma
antena e mulheres embora cada vez mais e
mais perto até a uma extensão de 67
tenho que encontrar se nessa situação
tinha uma duas coisas a fazer
o deputado ou prorrogavam a previdência
fé
vila inah do cabo o pato promotor então
esse poderia ser o tratamento hoje luis
gum tem alguns que ficaram todos já é
possível acessar aqui me atrevi enquanto
criança creche o seu berço
então vocês ao abordar a vida das duas
nessa história é conhecido de metal fio
primário foi uma página é da press
com este novo segmento fechou e kenyon
taxa foi no plantão para receber por
plantões por chegar se chegar a uma
audiência melhor e dessa é exaustiva
para achar esse mesmo show posição da
reportagem
desta vez na antena da sic podia ser
presa por terra essa taxa que eu fiz com
o pelotão mirim cotados para histórias
algumas delas que está a fim de que o
lyon história de eliana e gustavo alves
o
[Música]
o meu amiguinho a todo entre a noção
imprevidente e e e tem um campo de uma
maneira uma em cada mil mulheres em
campo durante a gravidez juliana que
ninguém soube há poucas semanas
é assim um dia eu vou dizer que sonhava
com isso na hora por dia é o pensar em
muita coisa é não confirma esse meu lado
nunca quis a fala em uma final que
efetivamente não sentimos nada da banhof
também sempre vai ver como é que nós
temos um projeto enter sério de 2014
séria em praia e mystic uninove dando
uma formanda mudou
é verdade mãe de três filhos explica que
este quarto bebê é muito desejável que
vem por essa razão quando numa primeira
fase e disseram que o melhor seria
interromper a gravidez senti o mundo
desabar
sem dúvida isto mesmo o fato bild.de eu
te ferir interromper com evidente ser eu
percebi uma coisa que vai contar tudo
que é onde menos valoroso jovem
a expectativa então o solo hã
el cambio obrigação chamar só do um
filho rejeitado pela comissão vilã que
fala de pintar o que esta história é
recente tem no final fish é evitar
totalmente o céu para o sábado o
terceiro romance a ser o velho que chega
sábado ao dinheiro não é quando mais
ninguém eu e história pela uff
é um descaso foi contada não viu este
ano de pai
nós pedimos a ópera chama cartão saúde
não tenha os quatro anos a falar em mais
uma sexta é um tema que usavam carvão
importado sociais e o tribunal a frase
faz que o que permite escolher hoje só
isto e eu me sinto isto é o saldo do
hotel
mas quem poderia se salvar foi ele ter
uma salva
nós vamos falar do amor quero ver se
você não sai daqui baseada no limite né
falcão falarmos de duas - a novela ela
descobriu que estava grávida
a ser tratada pela cia meio à troca e
ela sabia o depoimento que ela deu à
data mas não ficava mal formação do feto
eu vou descontar cuidado e calma bebês
sucesso e eles mesmo havia dito à mulher
se tivessem filhos enquanto mau tempo de
internet mais imagens e não não
conseguiu tomar a decisão de libertar se
de xadrez a quebra da empresa e do
castelo acaba por ser o caso com a
histórica porque ela pode assumir a
presidência não esperam dele é normal é
ter mulher viver com o sucesso enquanto
mamava essa
esse decreto esse movimento continuará a
funcionar nos atrapalhe muito cara
isso tudo no brasil quando ele chamou
toda na altura vivia e michel quanto
aqui na altura quando ela comentava um
medicamento por causa das novas estão
causado à mãe dela como é que estão em
volta
por favor escravo não tinha comido pelo
site que estamos a falar
não há poesia quando eu saí lá é tão
dura mas fez merda
michel faz em cima do adversário
mãe tu chinas eu estava tomando vista o
sonho
aos 22 anos descobriu que tinha leucemia
mielóide crônica poucos as pessoas vão
perguntar o que é isso sim eu costumo
dizer que é um tipo de cada um sabe um
dia eu provei que ia ser uma marca pela
primeira vez se tomava o imagine se o
remédio quando esse milagre crônico e
tive a minha primeira consulta ao seu
médico fila somos profissionais daquela
gravidez
se é que ela chegaria até o final e em
portugal não havia nenhum
em uma notícia de uma mãe que e fumava
em madrid e ao mesmo tempo tivesse
conseguido levar a gravidez até o final
e foram mesmo os nove meses muita
intensidade muitas emoções
muitos medos e muitas alegrias a foi a
minha filha nasceu nasceu saudável que
não chegou a tempo
nasceu a gritos e hoje é uma criança
extremamente saudável difícil apanhar
uma contestação ao avião se lia toda
minha
se forem curtir fazenda campo bom é tão
do meu dia de forma relevante o meu
ciúme é obviamente dias as pessoas
acordam com umas dores no corpo e acham
que vão ficar com sá deu a porta com as
manchas no corpo e acha leucemia voltou
eu disse a minha vida vai ser sempre
assim está na 13 a mãe e legal para
saber se é possível o tratamento ela não
teria esse ano não podia ser mãe nutria
contou precisar tanto ela quanto o
conselho dos médicos civil não sei mesmo
dentro dela usando como apoio o cheiro
dela
procure ou por 10 do xp investimentos
na hora as coisas também poder de voltar
para contar os alimentos
eu como como não está o homem de quantos
sejam estou só estas histórias em sinais
em processo de maturação são as mais
complicadas de crise fica no estado e
ficou me como é que nós condenamos às
vezes as nossas nossas próprias emoções
foi difícil nos ensinado abertas onde
ficam os nossos médios do mês temos na
memória dos que aqui foi sempre
conseguir contar essas histórias
condigna até hoje parecem sem causar
mais doenças crônicas
é difícil fazer o meu sentido muitas
vezes o goleiro apresenta que entender
essas pessoas quando elas tão
complicados
eu tenho sido um feedback entre os
leitores
a gente deu um sorriso e não tive
coragem do euro que não os consegue
censurar
não é fácil nós ouvimos a palavra tempo
pessoal nacional até os filmes olhar
seguinte maneira a caneta
por falar na famosa eu digo sempre que
isso não é mais um livro da sua vida e
faz a vida funciona para nós é um livro
sobre a vida real tem mais importantes
o homem como sinal no fim sou eu
uma moto
[Aplausos]
[Música]